احنا في صباح العربيه بدورنا سالنا
مراهقين في كل من مصر والاردن والعراق
والسعوديه عن رايهم بموضوع منع وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي عن المراهقين في عمر 13
عاما ولكن كيف يحمون انفسهم في هذا الفضاء
الواسع هذا ما سالناهم دعونا نتابع
الاجواء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اول حساب انشاته وانا عندي عشر سنين
انشات او الحساب لي سنه 2014 كانوا باقتام
سنه
2018 لاسباب عائليه شاتواصل مع عائلتي
وكان عمري 11 سنه فقط سويت حسابي في
السوشيال ميديا لما كنت الصف الرابع وكان
عمري عشر سنين
[موسيقى]
طبعا من حق المراهقه انه يستخدم الشرطه
الميديا لكن تحت ضوابط الاهل بطريقه
عقلانيه بس انه يمنعون الشخص من استخدام
الشخص من حقوقهم ما احس انه مقنع عشان كنت
صحباتي حيكون عندهم حسابات في السوشيال
ميديا وانا ما حيكون عندي فحاكون مختلفه
عنهم وما حقدر اتواصل معهم كثير طبعا انا
ضد هذه الحمله نمنع السوشيال ميديا عن
عني وعن الفعل في عمري لان احنا نواكب
هالمواكب التطور والتكنولوجيا في 2023 وما
بعد واحنا نجيل القادم صعبه جدا ان احنا
السوشيال ميديا لان اغرب الدراسه بقت
بالسوشيال ميديا واغلب وبقينا بنتواصل عن
طريق السوشيال ميديا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ايجابي نتواصل مع عائلتي وصاحباتي اكثر
وكمان ابدا اتعلم اشياء جديده في الحياه
من السوشيال ميديا
تعلمت على ثقافه جديده تعرفت على ناس جدد
واحيانا تفيدنا بالدراسه يعني نقدر نتواصل
مع المدرسين الخاصين
اما انت شفت مع السوشيال ميديا اكيد طبعا
ايجابيه لاني انا بدور على المحتوى
الترفيهي
وببتعد عن محتويات السلبيه في السوشيال
ميديا
تجربه ايجابيه لان بدرس من عليها وبقدر
اتواصل مع زمايلي وتجربه ايجابيه
[موسيقى]
بحمي نفس عن المحتوى السلبي
وبشاهد محترف الايجابيه وما بحكي مع حدا
في السوشيال ميديا او في مواقع التواصل
الا لما اكون عارفه في الحياه الواقعيه
واي حدا بعرف عن السوشيال ميديا بحاول
ابتعد عنه ما احكي ما اتواصل معه اكيد
الشخص الميديا مثل كل شيء بالحياه باشياء
ايجابيه اشياء سلبيه لكن انا استخدمت هذا
الضوابط واشراف الي وهي شنو تفادي المشاكل
واضرار الشخص الميديا لو احد غريب ضافني
ماله ولو احد ضايقني حسويلي بلوك واروح
اقول لاهلي وما اقدرش احمي نفسي من
السوشيال ميديا لانها يعتبر واخده مني
معظمه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات